preparations underway for the first
almost normal canada day celebrations in
three years it's pretty amazing i mean
it's the first time we've all been
together since covert this family from
montreal vancouver and amsterdam picked
ottawa for a canada day reunion it's
daniel's first time in the capitol
do you want to hold it daniel but with
hundreds of thousands expected to
descend on the downtown core there's
also some anxiety about so-called
freedom protesters among them this
business owner in the tourist popular
byward market is still deciding whether
to open it's just a question of
how many protesters or that kind of
thing they're expecting down here we
don't like trouble they're not going to
be warnings and second chances if the
law is broken regardless who breaks it
there'll be consequences ottawa police
are promising swift action for any
illegal activity
after being widely condemned for not
stepping in sooner during the original
convoy
you're not going to be allowed to set up
speakers to have a dance party or any
sort of tents to be able to camp or
have any sort of structures and we've
been very clear on that we are not
setting up an encampment in the city of
ottawa we are going to be at a campsite
40 minutes east of the city while a key
group organizing activities this weekend
in various places around parliament hill
is trying to calm resident anxieties
we're not monsters like the media is
portraying us to be
we're not violent there's a whole
continuum of violence and i think what
we saw in in february in particular was
the violence of words the violence of
taunts the violence of symbols and i
don't know that we're hearing enough
from conference organizers to really
make it clear that they understand that
side alex neve is a commissioner for the
newly launched grassroots ottawa
people's commission gathering
experiences of those impacted by
february's convoy he says anxiety
remains high in the community as canada
day looms and people aren't sure exactly
what to expect
abigail beeman global news ottawa